[موسيقى]
العالم يشهد نهايه الهيمنه الغربيه ليس
هذا راي محلل صحفي عابر او قول سياسيين
مناوئ للغرب وطرحته السياسيه والفكريه
وانما رؤيه جهر بها الرئيس الفرنسي قبل
التدخل الروسي في اوكرانيا واكدها من بعده
رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه السابق ومفكرون
وساسه غربيون يجمع مراقبون كثر على ان
الحرب الاوكرانيه تمثل نقطه تحول تنبئ
بتغييرات عالميه كبرى كما حدث اثر حروب
كبرى سابقه فهي جعلت الغرب اكثر اتحادا
لكنها اوضحت انه بات اقل نفوذا في العالم
فلم تسايره مواقفه تجاه روسيا قوه كبرى
حتى من المحسوبه في صف الحلفاء لكن كيف
سيكون النظام العالمي الجديد ومن هم
اقطابه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يتحدث عن عالم متعدد الاقطاب والرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن يتحدث عن نظام عالمي
جديد تتولى
قيادته وتوحد بقيه العالم الحر معها في
قصتنا الحروب بوابه النظم العالميه نرصد
كيف صارت الحروب بين القوى الكبرى النظم
العالميه على مدى قرنين من الزمن نستقرا
مع خبرائه مفكرين التطورات العالميه بعد
الحربين العالميتين الاولى والثانيه خلال
القرن الماضي وبعد انتهاء الحرب البارده
وما الات الوضع العالميه الراهن ونستكمل
بقيه هذه القصه مع الدكتور عمر عاشور
والساده الدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
في معهد الدوحه للدراسات العليا
والبروفيسور ماركو اويس استاذ تاريخ
الدولي والامن ومدير مركز الحرب
والدبلوماسيه بجامعه نسال ضيفينا الكريمين
عما ستكون له اليد العليا في تشكيل ملامح
النظام العالمي الجديد بعد الحرب
الاوكرانيه وعن نجاعه الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه لاحتواء الصين التي تراها
واشنطن المنافسه الوحيد
القادر على تغيير النظام العالمي كما نسال
عن دور القوى الاقليميه والدوليه الصاعده
في هذا النظام الجديد عن تاثير هذه
المتغيرات على عالمنا العربي لكن ما رايكم
بدايه ان نشاهد القصه وبعدها نبدا الحوار
[موسيقى]
جاءت الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا في
فبراير 2022
منذره بتغييرات في بنيه النظام الدولي
القائم منذ انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي عام
1991 تاتي الحرب في اطار سعي روسيا للتصدي
لسياسات الناتو شرقي اوروبا والتي يرافقها
تحركات امريكيه استراتيجيه في مناطق عده
مستفيده من دعم صيني لسياسات بوتين رافضه
للهيمنه الغربيه على النظام الدولي
هو عباره عن قواعد هو عباره عن اعراف
وعباره عن مؤسسات تتوافق عليها الدول حتى
تسير العلاقات الدوليه بشكل سلس او بشكل
مقبول لدى غالبيه هذه الدول لا يتشكل
لنظام الدولي بقرار يوقعه احد وانما يتشكل
خلال فتره زمنيه معينه
يستفيد منها المجتمع الدولي لمعرفه
النواقص اللي موجوده
ترغب روسيا بان ترى نظاما اكثر تمثيلا
ويعكس التغييرات في توازنات القوى
العالميه
نحن نرى ان هناك لاعبين اساسيين جددا
خصوصا في الجنوب لكن هناك اخرين ايضا وهم
يرغبون بتغيير العديد من المؤسسات الدوليه
من بينها الامم المتحده وايضا البنك
الدولي وصندوق النقد الدولي هذا يعني
اصلاحا عميقا جدا في النظام الدولي
الولايات المتحده تريد ان تجعل العالم
امنا للديمقراطيه الصين وروسيا تريدان ان
تجعله امنا للاوتوقراطيه لذا فكر في
العالم الليبرالي الديمقراطي الذي يطلق
عليه العالم الغربي المنفتح والمتعدد
المعزز من خلال الناتو ومؤسسات بريتن وودز
نظام مؤسساتي عالمي متطور جدا وراسخ منذ
امد بعيد مع خبره حقيقيه في كيفيه خلق
الامن والنمو الاقتصادي وحمايه القيم
كانت المحاوله الاولى في التاريخ الحديث
لبلوره نظام عالمي عقب حرب الثلاثين عاما
التي خاضتها اوروبا وانتهت بتوقيع معاهده
ويستفاليا عام
1648 والتي انهت سلطه الكنيسه واقرت مبادئ
سياده الدول وحدودها وعدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه
كان هذا شكلا جديدا من الدول وكانت هذه
الدول هي اللبنات الاساسيه للنظام
الاوروبي الذي نتحدث عنه فتلك الدول نمط
جديد قائم على مبدا السياده
بالطبع كانت هناك حروب بعد معاهده
ويستفاليا وكانت هناك صراعات بين الدول
الاوروبيه لكن معظم هذه الدول الى حد ما
قبلت شروط اللعبه
يمكن القول ان هذا النظام الاوروبي قد صمد
حتى الحروب النقبليونيه اي لفتره طويله
جدا
شكلت الحروب النقبليونيه البوابه الثانيه
لتغيير النظام العالمي فقد قامت سلسله من
الحروب بقياده نابليون بونابرت لنشر
الثوره الفرنسيه وحمايتها ضد ممالك اوروبا
وانتهت بهزيمه نابليون وعقد مؤتمر فيينا
عام
1815 الذي اكد على مبدا التوازن الدولي
واسس لمفهوم التنسيق الدولي لحل النزاعات
لتضاف هذه الاسس الى مبادئ معاهده
ويستفاليا ولتشكل مع مؤتمر فيينا مرتكزات
النظام العالمي انذاك
[موسيقى]
المشكله الاخرى بخصوص السياده هي مشكله
داخليه فالسياده تعني ان الملك يستطيع
تقرير كيفيه اداره الدوله ويمكنه ان يفعل
ما يحلو له مع رعاياه ولذا كنا نمتلك في
ذلك الوقت العديد من حالات الانظمه
الشموليه والقمعيه
والديكتاتوريات وما رافقها من مجازر
والمثال هنا هو الثوره الفرنسيه حيث انتفض
الناس واسقطوا الملك وبتلك الطريقه حصل
الاندماج بين الدوله والشعب وظهر مفهوم
الدوله القوميه
لم يصمد النظام الدولي المنبثق عن مؤتمر
فييناس وسنوات معدوده حتى تلاشى في ظل
تنافس شديد بدا اقتصاديا ثم امنيا بين دول
المركز امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر مع
المانيا والدوله العثمانيه وبين دول
الحلفاء بريطانيا العظمى وفرنسا وروسيا
فرضت الحرب العالميه الاولى نظاما عالميا
جديدا ضمن عده اتفاقيات اقرت نظام
الانتداب وانشات عصبه الامم لحفظ الامن
الدولي
نظام عصبه الامم كان بديلا ليبراليا لنظام
توازن القوى القديم حيث قدم ويلسون مبدا
جديدا يسمى مبدا الامن الجماعي وهو مبدا
جميل من الناحيه النظريه ويعني انه اذا
كانت هناك دوله معتديه على اخرى فان على
بقيه دول العالم الاتحاد ضد الدوله
المعتديه هذا يشكل راضعا ضد الاعتداء وهذه
فكره رائعه من الناحيه النظريه لكنها لا
تعمل بشكل جيد عند التطبيق
في تلك المرحله كان عصر الامبراطوريات
يتجه نحو نهايته فهناك اربع امبراطوريات
كانت قد تلاشت بالفعل كما كان هناك شعوب
ومجتمعات تتشكل وتسعى للحصول على حقها في
تقرير المصير والاستقلال والحكم الذاتي
لم تكن عصبه الامم تمتلك اليات تنفيذيه
فلم يكن هناك ما يشبه مجلس الامن
ولذلك كان من الصعب بشكل اساسي فرض اي
قرارات على الاعضاء اذا ما كانوا غير
راغبين باتباع بعض القوانين بانفسهم
ونرى ذلك في حاله المانيا وكذلك في حاله
الاتحاد السوفيتي
وفي النهايه ظهرت عصبه الامم عاجزه عن منع
اي صراعات كتلك التي بدات في الظهور خلال
عقد الثلاثينات ولهذا
ظهر في نهايه المطاف فشلوا عصبه الامم
لم تصمد عصبه الامم طويلا وتفاقمت
النزاعات بين بعض الدول الرافضه لاتفاقات
باريس للسلام والتي افضت لاندلاع الحرب
العالميه الثانيه عام
1939 بين دول المحور التي ضمت المانيا
وايطاليا واليابان ضد دول الحلفاء التي
ضمت فرنسا وبريطانيا والاتحاد السوفيتي
وانضمت اليهم لاحقا الولايات المتحده التي
تمكنت من وضع اسس النظام الدولي الجديد
لمرحله ما بعد الحرب السياسيا واقتصاديا
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه تم تصحيح
الاخطاء التي حصلت في المرحله الاولى في
بعض الحرب العالميه الاولى وخاصه الناحيه
الاقتصاديه الانهيار الذي حصل في الاقتصاد
بين الحربين تم محاوله استدراكه من خلال
بريتون وودز اتفاقيه من خلال انشاء صندوق
النقد الدولي من خلال انشاء البنك الدولي
بحيث انه يغطى هذا الموضوع ان الامر الاخر
تصحيح خطا حصل في عصبه الامم وهو اعطاء
للامم المتحده على الاقل من الناحيه
النظريه امكانيه استخدام القوه في فرد
القرارات الدوليه
لقد بذلت جهود حقيقيه لجذب السوفييت
ليكونوا جزءا من النظام الاقتصادي الموحد
لكن بالطبع لم ينجح ذلك ولم ينضم الاتحاد
السوفيتي لبريتانودز كانوا قلقين بشكل
اساسي من التبعات الداخليه لانضمامهم الى
هذا النظام المتداخل
في الاتحاد السوفيتي كانت هناك تناقضات لا
يمكن حلها بين الاشتراكيه والليبراليه هذا
عاد عن وجود تناقضات جيوس سياسيه بين
البلدين فكل منهما تبوء قياده الاجزاء
التي يسيطر عليها في العالم كلاه دولتين
ارادتا تشكيلا النظام الدولي وبالطبع
اندلع سباق تسلح غزه المنافسه بين موسكو
وواشنطن
بظهور الاتحاد السوفيتي وفكره الشيوعي
والولايات المتحده الراسماليه كقوى عظمى
بدا عهد جديد لنظام عالمي ثنائي القطب فقد
انضوى تحت كل قطب العديد من الدول ولم
يخفي الرئيس الامريكي عام
1947 نيته التصدي للتمدد السوفيتي عبر
استراتيجيات الاحتواء لتبدا بذلك ما عرفت
لاحقا بالحرب البارده وانقسم العالم الى
معسكر شرقي واخر غربي
كانت صراعا من اجل القوه والنفوذ يضمن
بناء تحالفات وتنافسا بين الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد السوفيتي على دول العالم
الثالث وعلى التكنولوجيا ايضا والتي مثلت
العنصر الثاني من هذه المنافسه وكان احد
جوانبها الخطيره هو تنافس من اجل التسلح
بما في ذلك امتلاك الاسلحه النوويه وهذا
يجعل من الحرب البارده حاله خاصه
[موسيقى]
منذ انتحار الاتحاد السوفيتي
بات هناك فراغ في السلطه شغلته بشكل اساسي
الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها قررت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ودول اوروبا الغربيه ببساطه تشكيلا نظام
الجديد عن طريق توسيع مؤسسات الحرب
البارده نحو ومن تلك المؤسسات الناتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي
انتهت الحرب البارده بسقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي عام
وتفكك المعسكر الاشتراكي ليهيمن عصر القطب
الواحد كنظام عالمي جديد
وتحولت غالب الجمهوريات المستقله عن
الاتحاد السوفيتي الى المعسكر الغربي اما
تحت منظومه الناتو او الاتحاد الاوروبي ما
ادى الى عوده النزاع بين المعسكر الغربي
وروسيا وحلفائها الى الواجهه بعد وصول
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين الى السلطه الذي
شكل وصوله بوابه تغيير جديد للنظام
العالمي اذ اندلعت الثورات الملونه في
جورجيا واوكرانيا اللتين حظيت بدعم غربي
فتدخلت القوات الروسيه لدعم انفصال
اقليمين ابخازيا واوسيتيا الجنوبيه عن
اراضي جورجيا عام 2008 وضمت روسيا شبه
جزيره القرم التابعه لاوكرانيا عام 2014
ودعمت الانفصاليين شرق اوكرانيا
لست متاكدا فيما اذا كانت روسيا تعارض
نظام الدوليه بشكل جذري لكنها تتحدى
الطريقه التي يتم فيها تطبيق واداره بنيه
النظام كما انها تدعي بان الغرب لديه حريه
التصرف وفق مصلحته في بعض مناطق العالم
بينما لم تحظى هي بنفس النظره الايجابيه
حينما ارادت هي الاخرى العمل من اجل
مصلحتها وضمن بيئتها
بالطبع لا يمكن لروسيا ان تغير النظام
العالمي بشكل احادي فهي لا تملك القوه
لفعل ذلك ولذلك فان القياده الروسيه تزعم
انها تعول على الدعم الذي من الممكن ان
تحصل عليه من بقيه الدول خصوصا من دول
الجنوب مثل الصين او الهند او البرازيل او
حتى بعض الدول في افريقيا والشرق الاوسط
التي لا تحظى بتمثيل مناسب في النظام
العالمي الحالي
كان العام 2021 مشحونا بارهاصات متسارعه
تنبئ بصراع دولي قادم فقد اعادت اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن خطط انتشارها
العسكري في العالم وخاصه في المناطق التي
تسهل احتواء روسيا والصين الى جانب تجديد
اوكرانيا رغبتها في الانضمام الى الناتو
وعلى الطرف المقابل رات روسيا في ذلك خطا
احمر جعلها تشن الحرب على اوكرانيا في
فبراير 2022
لقد انتهك بوتين المبدئين الثاني والثالث
من هذه المبادئ الثلاثه ويهدد بانتهاك
المبدا الاول وذلك عندما يلوح باستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
روسيا تريد نظاما متعدد الاقطاب لكن
الاقتصاد الروسي يعادل الاقتصاد الايطالي
او الاسباني لذا فهي ليست دوله عظمى الصين
هي دوله عظمى حاليا وهذا يعني العوده الى
نظام ثنائي القطب اعتقد
ان القياده الروسيه ترى ان هذا النظام غير
ديمقراطي ولا يعكس مصالح كل الامم
الموجوده في العالم وترى ان الولايات
المتحده قد تخطئ وانها قد تكون محكومه
برؤى قاصره ومصالح قوميه ضيقه ولذا يجب
على هذا النظام ان تعاد صياغته ويتم
تغييره
يمر عام على حرب روسيا ضد اوكرانيا التي
لن تكون خارطه السياسيه كما كانت عليه قبل
بدء الحرب تماما كما هو حال النظام الدولي
الذي قد يشهد تغييرا جزئيا او كليا
فلما ستكون اليد العليا في رسم ملامح
النظام الجديد
[موسيقى]
فاظن ان ستكون يعني انقاذ لفتره او نهايه
لفتره كبيره من التدهور التي حدثت في نقل
ما بين 2005
الى 2021 شهدت هذه الفتره
يعني تصريح الشهيد رئيس الاركان البريطاني
في 2010 بانه لا نستطيع هزيمه القاعده
شهدت هذه الفتره
انسحبت من العراق ومن افغانستان مؤخرا
شاهده
التصريح لايمانويل ماكرون على الموت
السريري شهدت كل هذه جاءت على فتره ذهبيه
لقوات التحالف الغربي منذ انهيار
السوفيتي في 25 ديسمبر 91 هذه الفتره
شاهدت حرب تحليل الكويت والتفوق العسكري
الهائل الجوي والارضي للقوات التحالف شهدت
محاوله وضع منظومه
لنقول النظام عالمي يحمي حق التدخل
للحمايه شهدتها في البوسنه في التدخل في
البلقان في خمسه وتسعين
بعد مجزره تحديدا في 95 ثم مجزره سوق
شهدت كذلك تدخل الوقف تهجير قصري وعمليات
تطهير عرقي في كوسوفو في 99 ثم بعد ذلك
شاهدت حتى التدخل في مارس 2011 لانقاذ
بنغازي من قوى نظام الليبي التي كانت
تواجه الثوار وقتها وتهدلت يعني تطهير
حاره حاره زنجا في في بنغازي فكان هناك
يعني هذا اطار
لنقل صحيح تفوق غربي لكن منظومه غربيه
تتدخل عسكريا في مناطق معينه
في حاله البلقان كانت مناطق امير الامم
المتحده
هذا يعني نقل في 2001 سبتمبر 11 سبتمبر
2001 انتهت انتهى بضربه اخذتها الولايات
المتحده يعني مثلت عدد الضحايا مثل الهجوم
على يعني كان اكثر
حوالي 3000 فكان اكثر من ما فعله الجيش
الامبراطوري الياباني في بيل هاربر با
اسطوله وبقوه الجويه
وكان في نفس السلا من القرارات التي اتخذت
بعدها شامله غزو افغانستان وهذه كانت ايضا
تحسب للقوى العسكريه ويعني كان في نفس
المنظومه انها سيطره على افغانستان بشكل
سريع للغايه وهزموا طالبان بشكل سريع
للغايه ثم ايضا غزو العراق وبعد ذلك
وتحولت للعمليتان من عمليه امنيه عسكريه
في افغانستان وعمليه يعني لا معنى لها في
في العراق الى عمليه احلال وسنبني
ديمقراطيات جديده كما فعلنا سابقا في
اليابان وفي المانيا وفي
كوريا حادث كوريا الجنوبيه وان كانت
مختلطه والبوسنه وغيرهم وطبعا
ما الذي كان يتفرج على كل هذا وياخذ
ملاحظات
كل الاعداء يعني نقل من القاعده الى
طالبان الى دول متوسطه كيران الى دول كبرى
كالصين وروسيا وما يحدث هذا
ولكنها لم تكن يعني في مكانها الصين
الجميع يتحدث عن انها ربما اخذت مكان كبير
جدا اصبحت قوى كبرى هناك من يتحدث انه حتى
اذا انهارت المنظومه الحاليه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هناك من يقول بانهارت
فعليا منذ ما حدث في العراق احتلال العراق
وافغانستان وان العالم باتم متعدد الاقطاب
بدخول هذه القوه الكبرى وان الصين هي التي
ستعدل الكف وليس روسيا التي وصفها احد
الضيوف بانها ليست قويه اقتصاديا اي ان
القوه الاقتصاديه ربما هي التي ستفرض
الصين في الكفه الاخرى مقابل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ليس فقط هذا هو الذي
حدث في هذه كله ان هناك كانت طريقه واحده
تقريبا للقتال ولفرض كل هذه المنظومه
الليبراليه الديمقراطيه التي كان فيها
يعني بعد نقل اخلاقي ولكن ايضا فيها بعد
تفوق وهيمنه عسكريه وسياسيه دلوقتي
المتحده وحلفائها لكن هذه كانت طريقه قتال
محدده الذين كانوا ياخذون النوتس ويلاحظون
كانوا ماستر في 2017 كان له تصريح شهير
يوجد طريقتين لقتال الولايات المتحده اما
طريقه غير
متكافئه او طريقه غير ذكيه
وهو كان يعني بذلك ان الغير الغير متكافئ
هو عباره عن غير نظامي او غير تقليدي بدا
هذا الموضوع من الصين الصين حين ضربت
سفارتها في عمليه
يعني محاوله حمايه الكوسوفيين في 1999 كان
في نفس التوقيت صدر كتاب يسمى بالحرب
الغير مقيده من بعض القياده العسكريه
الصينيه الذين وبعد ذلك من القيادات
اللغويه كان وقتها عقداء في القوات الجويه
والقوات والقوات البريه وصاروا بعض ذلك
القيادات وهي تتحدث عنا ان هذه الطريقه
للقتال فرصه فرصه جيش مقابل جيش ستكون
غالبا التفوق العسكري ويليه التفوق
السياسي وغيره والهيمنه دلوقتي المتحده
وبالتالي يجب ان تقاتل لكل الاساليب
الاخرى تفتح الموضوع
يشمل ذلك الحرب الاقتصاديه يشمل ذلك انشاء
جزر فائده البحر الصين الجنوبي وبعد ذلك
تقريبا القول بان هذه هذه الجزر بما ان
الخريطه حولها هي مياه اقليميه صينيه
بالتالي يعني
توسيع مفهوم الحرب ولذلك سميت الحرب الغير
مقيده الروس كانوا يفعلون نفس الشيء الروس
كانوا يعتقدون ان كل ما حدث في هذه الفتره
ما بين الفين الفين الثوره في صربيا بعد
حرب 99
وانتهاء ومرورا بالربيع العربي
وكذلك الثورات الملونه في 2003 2004 في
اوكرانيا 2005
في تونس وبعد ذلك في مصر كل هذا كان تخطيط
امريكي في اطار الحرب
الغير مقيده والحرب الهجينه وبالتالي يجب
ان نبرع نحن في هذه النوع من الحرب وسميت
البعض سماها خطا يعني عقيده جراثيمو
الاركان الروسي حاليا وسابقا وكان ابرع
تطبيق لهذا كان القيم 2014 على اهم بقع
جغرافيه في اوكرانيا دون تقريبا دون اطلاق
اطلقت بعض الطلقات ولكن ليس ليست حرب
حقيقيه وسقطت تقريبا دون قتال
كل هذا تقريبا انتهى نهايته كان في اغسطس
20 21 بخروج الولايات المتحده من
افغانستان امام قوى اضعف منها
ثم بناء عليه بعد ذلك الدخول اعلان بوتين
حرب في فبراير 22 على اوكرانيا اوكرانيا
حاله انتقال يعني قد تغير كل هذا
ذهبيه من 91 حتى 2001 فتره ذهبيه 2001 حتى
لنقل 2021 ما بين رماديه فتره رماديه في
البدايه ثم تدهور شديد حتى 2021 خروج الان
22 فصاعدا اوكرانيا ليس هجوم الروسي حقيقه
هي هو الصمود الاوكراني الهم الجميع صارت
هناك قوه ديمقراطيه حليفه في شرق اوروبا
اضعف تهاجم تقتطع اراضيها صبرت في 2014
بناء على تصريحات الحلفاء وال
تقف وتصمد امام القوه التي هاجمت اوكرانيا
في 24 فبراير 2022 هي عباره عن 200,000
تقديرات القتلى والجرحى والاسرى
والمفقودين هي 200 الف يعني القوه التي
هاجمت ابيدت وابيدت من قوه اصغر بكثير
وقوه حريفه الولايات المتحده وحليفه للغرب
وبالتالي هذه القوه يعني الهمت الباقي
تتحول من الموت السريري الى ضم قوه بحجم
فنلندا والى يعني تحول اخر فقد تكون امساك
شامبو لو هزمت اوكرانيا وضع اخر لو هزمت
اوكرانيا نستطلع وجهه نظر البروفيسور في
هذا الموضوع حقيقه نود ان نسالك اين نقف
باعتقادك اليوم من خلال هذا الصراع
المحموم لتغيير النظام العالمي القائم ومن
ترى باعتقادك انه ستكون له الغلبه من وجهه
نظرك
اعتقد ان هذا السؤال هو السؤال رائع وليس
لدي امكانيه لاتوقع من ستكون لديه اليد
العليا ما يجري في اوكرانيا وهذه الحرب
التي ادت الى تسريع وتيره بعض التطورات
كما قال زميلي في هذا البرنامج وسلط الضوء
على هذه الامور هذه التغيرات ليست تغيرات
مفاجئه طبعا الاعتداء الذي جرى من قبل
روسيا على اوكرانيا لم ياتي هكذا فجاه
وهذه الحرب لم تنتهي لا تزال مستمره ولا
نعرف ما
تؤدي به الامور في واقع الارض طبعا نحن
نتحدث عن
عمليات العسكريه التي كانت تشنها روسيا في
بدايه وكذلك
تسرعت وريتواتها في 2010 وهناك كذلك عدم
الرضا من قبل روسيا المرحله ما بعد الحرب
البارده كان هناك عدد من البيانات التي لم
تكن تستند على اي من الحقائق خصوصا عندما
يتعلق الامر بتوسع الناتو وعدم قبول قبول
روسيا لهذا النظام الجديد الذي تجد فيه
روسيا نفسها في وضع
يتقلص تدريجيا وكذلك هذه الحالات التصعيد
التي رايناها من قبل بوتين في الانظم
المجاوره اذا ما نظرنا الى الوضع الحالي
كما تمت الاشاره من قبل ضيفكم نعم بالطبع
ما حدث حقيقه هو لحده ما هو ادى الى
نتائج عسكريه بالنسبه لبوتين دول
الناتو وجدت انفسها او نفسها في صعوبات
جامه وكانوا يواجهون صعوبات لمعرفه
الاولويات الامنيه اذا هذه كانت بمثابه
فرصه لاعاده صياغه الليت واعاده التفكير
بالاولويات من خلال دعم اوكرانيا حتى هذه
الدول حتى مثل المانيا التي زادت من دعمها
بنسبه لاوكرانيا وهذا يعتبر تطور مهم جدا
عندما ننظر الى قرب الكثير من الحكومات
الالمانيه السابقه من روسيا ومن حكومه
بوتين ولدينا كذلك السويد وفنلندا طبعا
السويد ليس حتى الان لكن المحتمل ان تنضم
كذلك الى هذه التطورات التي ربما كانت غير
متماشيه مع السياسات التي كانت تنتهجها كل
من السويد وفنلندا راينا هذا التغيير يجري
حقيقه على الارض وراينا كذلك اعاده توحيد
الجهود من قبل الدول الغربيه والاوروبيه
واذا ما فكرنا وبحذر بشان ما يجري امامنا
فهذا يطرح اسئله بشان الى اي مدرسه تستمر
هذه الوحده ما بين الدول الاوروبيه والى
اي مدرسه تواصل الولايات المتحده دعمها
الى اوكرانيا ممتازه مهمه اليها الدكتور
بروفيسور الى اي مدى تستطيع الدول الغربيه
ان تبقى متوحده وقد سمعنا اصوات مختلفه
حتى فيما يخص الطرف الاخر الذي هو بدوره
يحشد بدا يحشد الاصوات معه مع روسيا الصين
العديد من دول حتى المنطقه في الشرق
الاوسط سمعنا انتقادات ايضا حتى من
المعسكر الغربي وبالتالي تساؤل حقيقه عن
الموقف الاخر الصين ماذا عن دورها في هذه
اللعبه انصحها التعبير هي التي ابدت رغبه
في وساطه في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه نتساءل عن نظره الاداره
الامريكيه للدور الصيني وربما الحجم
الصيني الذي بدا يكبر في هذه الازمه نعم
لكن مع حلفاء غير تقليديين ايضا
بشكل مقتضب الامر يعتمد على موقف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وما سيحدث هذا يعتمد
على الانتخابات الامريكيه القادمه هل
ستدخل الولايات المتحده في حاله عزله مع
الحكومه الجمهوريه وهل سيتم انتخاب الرئيس
الحالي مجددا وكذلك بالنسبه للصين
وعلاقتها والاولويات الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه
لاوروبا واوكرانيا عندما ننظر الى الصين
ما يثير الذهون هو ان موقف الصين هو ليس
موقفا بسيطا عندما يتعلق الامر باوكرانيا
من جانب الصين في الوقت الحالي تستفيد من
كون روسيا اصبحت تعتمد وبشكل كبير جدا على
الصين وكانه قلب للادوار الان الصين التي
كانت تعتمد ولي فتره طويله
التكنولوجيا الروسيه بدات تصبح مستقله
عندما يتعلق الامر باستخدام التكنولوجيات
اذا هذا سرع وتيره بناء القوات العسكريه
وخصوصا القوات البحريه ما نحتاج ان نفهمه
اوكرانيا وعلاقه الصين مع تايوان
مرتبطان مع بعضنا البعض خصوصا عندما ننظر
الى هذا الفهم
للحرب الحاليه وشن الحروب في العالم اذا
الصين تتعلم من الاستراتيجيات والعقيده
العسكريه الروسيه والقتال الذي يجري على
الارض والذي اثبت انه لم يعد ناجحا اذا ما
نظرنا الى اداء روسيا في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي الصين تستفيد من ذلك وبدات تفكر
حقيقه في هذا الامر الصين في الوقت الذي
يودون فيه اعاده مراجعه واستعراض وكذلك
تحويل وتغيير النظام الدولي لصالحهم الصين
صعدت لانها كانت جزءا من هذا النظام
العالمي لانه وبشكل مناقض للفتره التي
كانت فيها الحرب البارده حيث ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والغرب كان يواجهان
الاتحاد السوفيتي الذي كان ضعيفا اقتصاديا
لكن الغرب الان يتحدث عن هذه العلاقه مع
الصين لان سلسله التوريد طبعا هي مهمه
والتي تربط الغرب الصين والصين لابد كذلك
ان تتوخى الحذر لانه من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه الاسواق الغربيه والشركات
الغربيه تبقى مهمه بالنسبه للصين والصينها
بعض نقاط الضعف كذلك
يعني عندما يكون الحديث عن الصين يعني
دائما يربط بالجانب الاقتصادي على اهميته
لان له تداعيات سياسيه لكن الص وسؤالي هنا
الدكتور عمر عاشور يعني بدا نفوذها
السياسيه حتى يظهر مؤخرا يعني راينا
تدخلها حتى في منطقه الشرق الاوسط الوساطه
ما بين السعوديه وايران تعرض ايضا الوساطه
بالاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين هل سنرى دورا
سياسيا واضحا وجليا للصين باعتقادك في
المرحله المقبله هي قوه صاعده دون شك في
ذلك قوه صاعده على المستوى السياسي
والاقتصادي والعسكري كذلك لكن هو السؤال
الوجيه هل ستكون القوه الدوليه بمعنى تاخذ
دور الولايات المتحده ام ستكون قوه
اقليميه بمعنى انها تريد الحفاظ على
نفوذها في منطقتها شامله لان البعض بدا
يتموقع مع روسيا والصين راينا ربما مجموعه
التي حتى العرب نحن كعرب دول عربيه لم تعد
يعني تخفي بانها تنتمي لطرف قد يغضب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكنها لا
تجاهر بذلك هو مجموعه
[موسيقى]
تايوان في 207 وعشرين مدى في عشرين سبعه
وعشرين سن الرئيس
وانظري للاستراتيجيه الصينيه ان هذا هي
اوجه قوه الصين بعد ذلك قد يكون هناك
انحدار في المستوى الديموغرافي في المستوى
الاقتصادي وحتى في مستوى ربما يعني لحاق
الولايات المتحده
واستعاده نفوذها فبالتالي انا ارى ان
اولوياتهم ستكون في منطقتهم الان حتى في
اجتماعات الاخيره
نعم كانت منذ ايام يعني
فيما يخص هذا ولكن هذه ايضا خلفيه الصين
هذه اسيا الوسطى جمهوريات اسيا سابقه لكن
الان كلهم ينظرون للصين
كشريك اقتصادي وربما سياسي العسكري
والامني ما زالت روسيا يعني كلهم حضروا
الاحتفاليه في 9 مايو في حرب او انتصار
الروسي في او اتصاصي في حل العاميه
الثانيه حضرب هؤلاء الرؤساء
مازال هذا فقط علامه على انه روسيا ما
زالت ما زالت هناك عسكريا وامنيا مع صعود
الدور الصيني كذلك في اطار اقليمها وربما
يكون لها نفوز لكن التوجه العام انه لن
احب محل الولايات المتحده هذا طبعا نحن
اشلنا لمجموعه الست وهي هذه القمه التي
تراستها الصين في هذه المنطقه شيئا التي
قيل بانها عاصمه الامبراطوريه القديمه وهي
بدايه طريق الحرير وراوا ايضا فيها ربما
رساله مواجهه للغرب في هذا الخصوص اعود
اليك البروفيسور حقيقه ونتساءل يعني خبراء
الغربيون يتحدثون عن ان الحرب
الاوكرانيه ربما قد جعلت الغرب اكثر توحدا
لكنه بدا اقل نفودا بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه
مشاكل المعسكر الغربي كما تراه باعتقادك
نعم هذه هي المحاججه التي نسمع بشانها ان
هناك تجديد للوحده الغربيه لكن هناك مشاكل
تواجه هذه القوى الغربيه وهي تتعلق بحجم
دعم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعد
الانتخابات القادمه من سيكون الرئيس
الجديد في الولايات المتحده هذا سيملي
السياسات التي سيتم اعتمادها هذه الدول
الغربيه هي لم تستثمر بشكل كافي في قواتها
العسكريه اذا لدينا ربما قوتين مثل
بريطانيا وفرنسا وبولندا بدات تبني قواتها
العسكريه حتى تكون لديها قوه قتاليه لكن
هناك ضعف
والمانيا كذلك لديها اجنده مختلفه حتى لو
كانت تحاول ان تبني جيشها لكن هناك بعض
النقاط نقاط الضعف في الغرب لكن ثم نظرنا
الى اوكرانيا مثلا هي التي ادت الى ضروره
ان يكون هناك وحده جعلت الامر ملحا
بالنسبه للغرب
المانيا هي تعتبر اقوى اقتصاد اوروبي
وتعتمد بشكل كبير جدا على الاسواق الصينيه
هذا التضارب وهذه الاختلافات لا تتعلق في
علاقتها بروسيا وحرب على اوكرانيا وانما
هي تجل لعلاقات
تتجلى مع الصين عندما نظرنا الى ماكرون
عفوا عندما ذهب الى الصين وعندما نظرنا
كذلك الى ان وقال ان اوروبا لابد الا
تواصل
اتباعها لسياسات الامريكيه ولابد ان تصبح
مستقله بعد زياره للصين هذا ما المح اليه
ماكرون اذا اذا ثانيا هناك كذلك
اوروبيه كذلك تنظر الى عندما ننظر الى
اوروبا اذا لدينا هذه الاولويات
الاستراتيجيه المرتبطه بالدول الاوروبيه
الجنوبيه التي تركز على قضايا الهجره
والارهاب وهناك دول اوروبيه في الشمال
التي تركز على التهديدات التي يرون انها
اتيه من روسيا ولدينا كذلك الدول الاخرى
مثلا مثل استراليا هذه الدوله هي مستقله
من الناحيه الامنيه مستقله عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهي ستتعاون بشكل كبير
جدا مع الولايات المتحده عندما ننظر الى
ما جرى اذا ما حدث حقيقه هو انه كان هناك
ومن خلال
العمل العسكري الصيني لم تكن هناك كذلك
ادانا لروسيا اذا كان هناك كذلك تهديدات
نراها في منطقه المحيط الهادي وكذلك في
منطقه بحر جنوب الصين هناك دول كثيره
تحاول ان تقف الان مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وطبعا هناك كذلك الهند الهند
التي لديها كذلك
عدد من
النديه مع الصين من الناحيه الامنيه لكنها
تبقى قريبه من روسيا بسبب النفط الروسي
ولا تريد ان تقف مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ربما
الجميع يحاول التوقع التوقع بالفعل في هذه
اللعبه الحادثه الان اتحول الدكتور عمر
عاشور ونتسائل حقيقه ماذا عنا نحن العالم
العربي ماذا عن خياراته كيف يحسبها انه لا
يحسب الموضوع ينتظر يتفرج لمن الغلبه
وبالتالي يكون تابعا له ام ان هناك تفطن
لهذا الموضوع وقد راينا مثل ما ذكرنا بعض
المواقف التي باتت لا تخشى من على الاقل
تظهر بانها ليست تابعه تماما الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وليست ضد روسيا اي انها
تحاول ربما ليس اللعب على الطرفين لكن على
الاقل لا تظهر ميلا واضحا لطرف دون اخر
ننتظر استقلالا يعني هو يوجد ذلك ولكن لا
يوجد وحده رؤيه عربيه واضحه وكذا كيف ترى
مختلف المواقف توجد مواقف يبدو انها كانت
تحاول الاستفاده من الموقف
بطريقه او باخرى يعني كما رؤيه في بعض
التسريبات كانت هناك دول عربيه تريد ان
تسلح روسيا وتمدها ببعض قضايا في 122 مللي
ولكن بضغط امريكي يبدو انها حولت التوجه
من روسيا الى اوكرانيا فهذا موقف
للاستفاده الماديه بالاساس توجد دول اخرى
حاله السعوديه مثلا حاولت ان تتوسط في
امور ربما تقرب عبر مثلا تبادل الاسرى
سبقات تبادل الاسرى عبر التهدئه عبر
هنا قطر كانت في اتجاه ايضا قطر معروفه
السلام في محاوله تهدئه الاطراف كلها
وربما التوسط في فتره لاحقه
يوجد توجهات مختلفه كيف يمكن الاستفاده من
هذه اللعبه التي يبدو الجميع راينا قوه
كبرى يعني
ضيفنا الكريم ويتحدث عن استراليا عن عده
دول تحاول ان تتموقع باعتقادك كيف يمكن ان
تستفيد
يستفيد العرب
يعني هي تاثير الرئيسي علينا خاصه بواحد
مواضيع متعلقه بالامن الغذائي وامن الطاقه
يعني لا شك ان الاسعار تقع بالذات ترتفع
فالدول المصدره للنفط والغاز وهكذا ستكون
مستفيده
يوجد موضوع المتعلق
الوساطه والدبلوماسيات السلام والمبا هذا
سيعطي نفوذ اكبر لسيادات الخارجيه العربيه
من ناحيه الثانيه من ناحيه ثالث البعد
العسكري والدفاعي توجد خطوره هنا انه هذه
دوله كبيره حاولت ان تقتطع اجزاء من دوله
صغيره ولو انتصرت بدعم والدوله الصغيره
مدعومه من النيتو في ظهرها لو انتصرت اظن
ان الوضع الدول العربيه الصغيره تعرض لمثل
هذا من الكويت تعرضت لمثلاثه
فيوجد بعض هدد بهذه الطريقه
ورغبه ان حليفه النيتو اظن ان سيكون هناك
اعاده تفكير في القدره الدفاعيه والامنيه
لعدد من الدول العربيه لو فشلت فهذا خبر
جيد ولكن لو فشلتنا في تقديري الكل سيعود
للهجين
نموذج الكرم لان نموذج القرم كان غير مكلف
غير اخلاقي مطلقا ما اختراقات استخباريه
عمليه اغتيال عمليات خطف عمليه تضليل بابا
جاندا عمليات نفسيه وهكذا
وتامين فقط النصر بالانزال الجوي والبحر
يعني ناصر تحقق قبل القتال يعني فلو هزمت
روسيا اظن سيكون هناك عوده للهجين مره
اخرى وهو ايضا يعني له تداعيات امنيه
ودفاعيه على الصغيره اساسا
وبرضه العربيه الاخرى
لو تكرمت كيف ترى ان تداعيات
السيناريوهين ان صح التعبير فيما يخص
الحرب الدائره الان في اوكرانيا
نقول ما سيحدث لكن ما نواجهه حاليا كان
فعلا طريقا مسدودا لم يتمكن اي من الطرفين
بان يستخدم كل القدرات العسكريه وكذلك
البشريه لتغيير القاعده المتبعه وتغيير
قواعد اللعبه على الارض اذا عندما بدات
العمليات العسكريه كان هناك القوات
الروسيه التي بدات تعزز قدراتها لكن من
الصعوبه ان نعرف ما ستكون النتيجه عليه
نعم لا ترغب ان يوفر المزيد من الاسلحه
بالنسبه للاوكران لكن هناك بعض
التحفظ خصوصا بالنسبه للذخيره التي ليست
بلا نهايه وبالتالي السؤال هل اوكرانيا
سيكون بامكانها ان تحقق نجاحا على الارض
في المستقبل
المنظور خصوصا لابد ان ناخذ الاعتبار اذا
ما تغير الرئيس ارجو ان تبقى معنا دكتور
عمر كلمه اخيره في عجاله هو فقط نسيت
الدروس العسكريه لانه الحرب الاوكرانيه هي
مدرسه عسكريه للدول الصغيره
والاكثر نقل ضعفا في مواجهه الدول اقوى
منها فيما يخص دور قوات الاحتياط فيما يخص
صدور المدفعيه فيما يخص دور الدفاعات
الجويه فيما يخص منظومات الصواريخ القصيره
والمتوسط المدى فيما يخص القدره على
المضادات الارضيه للدفاعات الجويه كم هائل
من الدروس العسكريه والدفاعيه التي يمكن
ان يستفاد بها وكان في منطقه اشكرك جزيل
الشكر دكتور عمر عاشور استاذ دراسات
الامنيه الاستراتيجيه في معهد الدوحه
للدراسات العلية هنا في قطر ومن لندن
اشكال بروفيسور استاذه تاريخ الدولي
والامن مدير مركز الحرب والدبلوماسيه
بجامعه حلقتنا دمتم في رعايه الله والسلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]